S
[Música]
isso é próprio
S
[Música]
Não trabalha
e quando eu entrei
pergunta
consegue
críticos
e de lá
eu realmente queria
durante um ano
S
e eles passaram algum tempo
[Música]
sim
S
vai ser muito desigual
[Música]
seria imaginado
durante o estudo
com algum desenvolvimento frontal ativo
mais
um dia
[Música]
é um hospital
para primeiro
[Música]
Oh
S
[Música]
finalmente
e mais perto
sobre o tempo e procissão
Foi quando um dia
S
vamos lá você quer estar no topo porque é
essencial para manter
[Música]
e cobrir
S
nerd
Oh
acredite em mim é um ponto
S
quanto ao combustível
hoje vivemos
não
várias vezes terminado
Estou indo embora
[Música]
passando a visita do dia
não sei onde
Oh
[Música]
fluxo puro
precisava
e muito mais
[Música]
qual é o problema
baixo risco e se através
OK
d
[Música]
S
a sociedade
[Música]
eu
para mudar
nós queremos passar
de dia
Boa
[Música]
sozinho
[Aplausos]
qual é a razão
mesmo
S
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e hoje
mais
material
[Música]
não
a ele
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Oh
e
Obrigada
Deus
eu
[Música]
mais
não
S
[Aplausos]